In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sienachsadion from A30th, on which we commemorate our righteous father
Ezekius, Abbot of Dalmatus.
On the 30th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our venerable father Isaac, the confessor,
founder of the monastery of Dalmatus in Constantinople.
Our Holy Father Isaac was Assyrian Hermit, who lived in the desert during the time of the
persecution of the Orthodox under the emperor Valens.
In 378, when the emperor was preparing to leave on a campaign against the Goths who were
masked on the banks of the Danube, threatening Constantinople, St. Isaac, animated by a divine
impulse, presented himself before Valens and said to him, Your Majesty, order the churches
to be reopened and you will return victorious.
The sovereign merely turned distinctively away from him.
The next day, the man of God came once again and repeated his request, but Valens turned
aside once more.
On the third day, Isaac barred the emperor's path, gripped the bridal of his horse and did
not stop repeating his request at one moment as a supplication and another as a reproach.
When they came to a deep gorge full of briars, the exasperated emperor commanded his guards
to throw the saint into the gorge.
By God's grace, Isaac landed on the briars as on a featherbed, and two young men, radiant
and clad in white, pulled him out of the gorge without delay and carried him safe and sound
to Constantinople, to the middle of the Agora, before the emperor who had just arrived.
Superfied, Valens asked him if he were truly the man he had thrown into the ravine.
The saint replied, Open the churches, and you will return in joy.
If you refuse, know that, after you have saved your life by fleeing, you will perish, burned
by your enemies in a haystack.
Overwhelmed as he was by this revelation, the emperor remained no less stubborn and
appointed two senators, Saturn and Victor, to guard Isaac until his return.
The battle fought near Andrianopolis, on the 9th of August of 378, led to the defeat of
the imperial troops.
Valens succeeded in escaping and hid himself with his aid to comp in a haystack.
The barbarians who were pursuing him discovered him there and set fire to the haystack, and
thus the tyrant perished wretchedly, and Isaac's prophecy was fulfilled.
When the troops who had managed to escape the carnage returned, some of them wishing to test
Isaac said to him, Prepare yourself to give an account of your actions for the emperor
has returned.
But the saint replied, The stench of his charred bones
have assailed my nostrils for more than seven days.
When Thodosius the Great came to power, he informed of these events and of the part played by
the Holy Monk, set him free, and proclaimed without delay a decree returning to the Orthodox,
the churches that had for forty years been denied them.
Isaac declared that, having accomplished his mission, he would return to the Syrian desert
but Satanios and Victor begged him with tears to stay in the city, to re-establish the monastic
life which had fallen into disrepute.
In the end he agreed, on condition that they build him a cell in a quiet and retired place
where he might finish his days in Ezekiah.
The two senators becoming his spiritual sons rivaled each other in suggesting suitable places
and he finally settled on a small property offered by Satanios, situated outside the city
at that time in the district of Samathia near the Xedolophos Gate.
He settled in a modest cell and began to live an exemplary, aromatic life.
Each morning the two senators would go to the hermit to receive his blessing before looking
to their affairs, and an increasing number of devout people came to visit him, conversing
with him about the true faith and the spiritual life.
Emperor Thodosius himself would frequently go to Isaac to receive his counsel and ask him
to intercede with God for him and for the empire.
Many Christians would invite him to their homes and rejecting all vanglory the saint would
sometimes leave his cell to visit them.
Thodos gradually joined him and the place became the first monastery in Constantinople in
the year 382.
Under his influence other monastic communities were formed in the city as well as near it including
that of St. Epatius in the monastery of the Rufianianas.
St. Isaac would visit them all regularly and exhort them to spiritual zeal.
Although he had no official authority he was honored as the father of all the monks in
the capital.
When he learned of people who lacked the necessities of life, he, if he had nothing to give
them himself, would inform wealthy Christians who would send them food and clothing.
At that time St. Isaac thus presided not only over the work of teaching the faith and guiding
the spiritual life of the city, but also over the works of charity and benevolence.
When St. John Chrysostom was appointed to the Episcopal throne of Constantinople in the year 398,
he, seeing that a great number of monks had the habit of moving around the city and of
paying visits to private households, took action against this abuse and ordered them to
remain in their monasteries.
He also undertook to reorganize the works of charity, in particular by the founding of
a number of large hospitals whose leaders he chose himself.
These necessary pastoral measures cast St. Isaac's activity into the shade, and he felt himself
pushed aside.
Thelfilos, Archbishop of Alexandria, knew how to exploit these differences.
When he arrived in Constantinople, in order to turn the accusations made against him
against the Holy Patriarch, he drew Isaac and his monks to his cause.
Unhappily by this means, the old ascetic played an active part in the Synod of the Oak in 403,
as an accuser of St. John Chrysostom who was then deposed and sent into exile.
This condemnation provoked such reaction that the Holy Bishop was soon recalled to his
see, unfortunately, only for a short time.
St. Isaac did not involve himself further in ecclesiastical affairs, but spent his last days
peacefully in his monastery.
Having been warned by God of his approaching departure from this life, he gathered together
his disciples, exhorted them to remain firm in the true faith, and designated Dalmat
Zeus as his successor.
He then gave his soul into God's hands in the year 406.
He was mourned by the entire population, the emperor at its head.
After the religious ceremony in the cathedral, presided over by the Patriarch, a courtage
was formed to transfer the saint to his monastery for burial.
St. Aurelion, one of the courtiers and a fervent admirer of Isaac, stationed a large number
of soldiers along the route.
These snatched the precious body and took it to be placed in the crypt of the church which
Aurelion had built in honor of Saint Stephen.
While the monks, forced to accept this devout show of strength, returned to their monastery,
deprived of the consolation which the relics of their spiritual father might have given
them.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.